the last thing that kobe bryant would
have ever wanted
is controversy between his wife and her
mother he
adored vanessa's mom i can tell you that
for a fact
but sophia lane is making claims about
vanessa
that have forced the grieving widow to
speak out
beyond hurtful that's how vanessa
describes the tell-all interview
her mom just did with a spanish language
network
[Music]
in it the 67 year old grandmother fights
back tears claiming
vanessa told her to move out of her
house and return her car
vanessa fired back at her mom for having
the quote
audacity to do an interview on tv
talking negatively about me while
shedding tears about a car
and home that wasn't in her name vanessa
says she and kobe have supported her
over the past 20 years and she will
continue to do so
as to what caused the rift sophia is not
sure but she claims it started after
vanessa texted her
she was quote stressing her too much
vanessa also says her mom quote
has not been physically present or
emotionally supportive
for my daughters and me after my husband
and daughter passed
away meanwhile e.t has confirmed that
vanessa is suing the la county sheriff's
department
over photos allegedly taken of kobe and
gianna at the crash site
back in january in her court filing
vanessa claims that quote
faced with a scene of unimaginable loss
no fewer than eight sheriff's deputies
at the crash site
pulled out their personal cell phones
and snapped photos of the dead children
parents and coaches the deputies took
these photos for their own
personal gratification the lawsuit also
claims that vanessa is in constant fear
the photos will be leaked he was my
sweet husband and the beautiful father
of our children
vanessa is seeking unspecified damages
for
severe emotional distress the sheriff's
department had no comment on the lawsuit
quote
due to the pending litigation